- I loved the movie.
My whole family, we sat
down and watched it.
It is so great,
you are so great!
But one question: Did
that hurt your voice?
'Cause you were like,
(grunts)
the whole time.
(laughs)
- Oh my God, oh my God!
- Oh my God! (screams)
(laughs)
(phone rings)
I am so hot and sweaty right now.
You have no idea how
jealous I was of you, Josh.
I've been dying to get to this thing,
and not an apart thing,
and I was gonna do Artemis Fowl first,
but oh my God!
I can't even believe I'm talking to you!
How are you?
Hi I'm Kelly.
- I'm good.
Hi Kelly, we met once before.
- I know, but you don't understand,
that Goonies reunion,
like Sean,
I needed it like
like a fat kids needs cake.
I was like,
I literally,
I...
I've been so sad like this last week,
'cause it's so much work and our kids,
and I got on Amazon
Twitter and I was like,
what is this,
and somebody kind of was talking about it,
and then my show said are
you gonna interview Josh,
and so I started looking at it,
and I watched every second
a... twice.
I watched it twice,
because I loved that
y'all redid the lines,
the best ones.
I loved that everybody got on.
Like was that so cool?
- Josh did,
Josh is, I mean,
these kind of situations
when there's drama,
and there's you know pain, and whatever,
there's always an opportunity
for something good to happen,
and Josh just,
because he's a true fan,
and because he is who he is,
he like brought the band back together,
like legit.
And a
(laughs)
- It's my favorite childhood movie,
like you and the Labyrinth,
this is my, this is just
happening right now.
- You weren't even bored man?
Come on.
- I know, but I'm a decade
younger than my brother,
and seven and a half years
younger than my sister,
so I watched all
I didn't get to choice to
watch, I didn't get to chose,
so I still watch all of those,
and they were,
oh my God, I love y'all so much.
You have no idea.
I was so.
- Josh, how much do you just
wanna hug this girl right now?
- I wanna hug you both so much
- I would so risk Corona Virus
right now for a group hug.
You have no idea.
(laughs)
- I just
- Go, no Sean go.
- No, I was just gonna say,
looking at the three of us,
I'm pretty sure it's like
two brothers and a sister.
I'm pretty sure that we're all like...
(laughs)
- I will be your family.
- You are.